Sonia what could all this mean for the
up-and-coming space tourism industry
yeah hi good morning Olivia yeah the
most recent tragic events really raises
questions about number one the viability
of space tourism but also just what's
gonna happen from here on up the
timeframe I spoke to Marco Sisera is he
the space analyst at the teal group and
he said because we're talking about
Richard Branson's company having this
huge issue well that is going to
essentially set back the industry one
two three years now he's a lot more
optimistic than another analyst named
Michael blades at frost & sullivan who
says this industry is gonna get setbacks
in three to five years I mean regardless
a couple issues need to really be ironed
out number one safety standards he'd be
clearly delineated number two more
testing to be done in the Virgin
Galactic client this was just the fourth
time the rocket was tested then they had
this monkey goal of going up as early as
in a couple of months in spring of next
year and also more mixtures of fuel and
different systems need to be tested as
well know what I'm always drunk by is
the fact that I mean Branson back in
2010 said he might be you know flying in
orbit with his son by 2012 I actually
spoke to him in 2012 he said that they
would be doing it by the end of 2013 and
it wasn't just his ambition to travel up
in space for passengers he actually saw
this as been major game changer for the
whole commercial air travel industry
take a look and take a listen at to what
he told me back at the farnborough
airshow in 2012 this could be the
started with you know sending people
from you know say great britain to
australia in three or four eyes so for
years now Branson is saying that this
will be done in a sort of a 12-month
horizon obviously the tragic accident on
Friday pushes that uh rise and back even
further for some of the other players
here in this
who's sort of leading the pack well
clearly he's the pioneer and as a result
of that he was able to garner some 800
willing people who are believing him
believing his mission to put people in
space he's already collected somewhat
close to 80 million dollars as a result
of it he's a pioneer according to Marco
at the teal group but not just that the
other three players include Xcor
aerospace Sierra Nevada as well as Blue
Origin will be interesting to see who
exactly maintains the number-2 status
because number one of course perhaps
going to Virgin Galactic but if you take
a look at Xcor aerospace for example
according to Marco they've done some
test flights but they're not there's not
much of a track record as of yet they
haven't given a timetable their biggest
issue is of course funding because
they're not backed by billionaires so
and they're not quite yet selling
tickets on their spaceship for two
hundred thousand dollars yeah no one's
really given clear timetable if you take
a look at Sierra Nevada they're working
on their version called The Dream Chaser
they didn't get a contract from NASA
when NASA gave a money out a couple
months ago but they have met all of
NASA's requirements and according to
teal group this is probably one of the
safest they've done several tests and
lastly you have blue origin which of
course is backed by Jeff Bezos and in
true Amazon style he's offering the
low-cost option but again he hasn't
given a timetable no doubt a very
important issue and it looks like the
industry is going to take a pic and of
course after all the after the tragic
accident much more likely that
regulators will get involved which would
likely so every base tonight cable down
as well that's a good thing the fact
that the regulators are looking into
this with the very prudent lens is
important because say fees yeah most
folks please of course Bloomberg's Mia
Saini thank you so much